i mean i just never thought that a year
ago
we would be here today yeah for real i'm
just ready for mama to open up that door
yeah i know go lana
you wanna knock that doorbell nope
that's loud say gj
[Applause]
hey y'all hey
um i think i forgot something in the car
well you go inside okay
and play real quick i'll be right back
okay
alana you know i was
uh super excited for the girls to come
up and see us um
and i guess i was overlooking the damage
that i have done
you know i have heard her a lot and it's
it's going to take some time to get
through this
alana you good
it's just i haven't seen him in so long
so it's a little
it's a little much he's a little awkward
i kind of expected mama to come to the
door
not him yeah
that's like the first time i've seen him
since i got out of rehab and everything
so like i mean if you don't feel
comfortable instead
we'll go get a hotel room if we got to
we're here to see what mama's doing i
don't really give what he's done to be
honest
hey team there's gigi
there's gigi where is your mommy and
alana atting
i'm not right uh why i
don't really know i really hope the
girls have a good time
because a big chunk of our recovery has
been based here in florida
and so if i could get the girls to move
down here i mean
everything will be complete so please
you know do not mess this up for me